je vous demandais à toutes et tous de
tendre l'oreille écoutez bien
ce sont ces tensions enregistrées par un
nerf potes vous savez ces oreillettes
sans fil pour iphone muni d'un micro
depuis l'estomac d'une jeune américaine
de 27 ans en voulant prendre un cachet
début profane l'a avalé son erp odin son
kit écouteurs blancs sans fil et en
bonnes influences heusèle s'est
immédiatement filmer pour le raconter
une vidéo qui a autant amusé
qu'inquiéter les internautes j'avais
l'ibuprofène 800 dans une main et mon
[ __ ] des repos de gauche dans l'autre
et j'ai pris une gorgée de ma bouteille
d'eau et puis je me suis rendu compte
que c'était pas l'ibuprofène que j'avais
à balai
et j'ai essayé de vomir je deviens folle
donc cédé et des vidéos sur les réseaux
au lieu d'aller à l'hôpital enfin qu'est
devenu l'airpod rennes après ce petit
voyage dans son tube digestif et bien a
priori il fonctionne nous dit elle même
si elle ne l'aiment pas réutiliser elle
l'a gardé bah oui
un film qui est sortie dans l'espace à
bord de l' iss absolument ah oui je suis
dans cette arme mais il va demander
gentiment elle et on a des lui refuser
quelque chose à thomas pesquet s'est dit
oui et en combien de temps il était
livré non il est parti avec commencé
c'est maintenant il est parti avec la
série le film il a fallu faire passer
par un tout petit tuyau puisque grande
surprise le tuyau entre nous est lié
sait pas si gros que ça en fait ils ont
pas un internet de ouf donc alors là je
voudrais c'est la vraie annick c'est
bien ça l'histoire
[Rires]
nous insulte on le sait même pas bonjour
madame chanas
bon qu'est ce qui vous choque
malheureusement abba malheureusement je
peux entendre il a dû le voir sur une
petite machine comme ça et là et je sais
pas j'ai loupé son coup de fil ah oui je
vous racontais un truc qui m'énerve
quand je reçois sur mon téléphone un
numéro que je connais pas je réponds pas
comme mon avis beaucoup d'entre nous
parce que c'est souvent des machins de
téléphone de trucs de voilà donc je
réponds pas c'était lui de lits ssr
terminée pardon je t'ai koupéla
[Applaudissements]
c'est le début d'un long voyage pour ce
vaisseau de la nasa
lancé hier soir depuis la californie il
doit parcourir 11 millions de kilomètres
en dix mois
l'objectif de la mission baptisée d'arte
fléchettes en anglais et de dévier la
trajectoire d'un astéroïde pour protéger
l'humanité d'une éventuelle collision
non
il est drôle non oui mais jamais vous
voulez deux places pour son spectacle
bah pourquoi pas avec plaisir bah c'est
pour moi c'est cadeau
[Rires]
parce que moi dans mon spectacle
vraiment l'idée du mot spectacle c'est
le vivre ensemble si ça peut les changer
d'avis la bd grand plaisir de venir il
ya un peu d'agitation et quand même
beaucoup d'agitation mais d'avancer je
veux pas dramatiser la situation c'est
pour ça que je parle d'un peu de
situations avec les formes de
l'organisme qui sont en train de se
positionner
devant nous pour essayer de rentrer
alors l'idée non plus effectivement
c'est pas de faire de la provocation
enfin ramé ont fait pas de provocation
on est vous êtes journaliste je suis
dégoûté nous sommes partout chez nous
c'était la suite de ma frappe justement
je suis qui dit qui y est d'abord c'est
marine le pen qui se baladent
[Applaudissements]
à se ballader tombe sur une théière la
fraude génie qui sort et je lui dis
alors tu as le droit un veut pas droit 3
venons ici tant dans le 93 est en droit
vous dis bon bah écoute et j'aimerais
j'ai une arrière arrière grand mère que
j'ai jamais connu j'aimerais bien
l'avoir dit ben non on ne peut pas
ressuscité des morts alors est ce que
vous pouvez faire que toute la france
même l'autre jeune l'adn est enterrée ou
ta grand-mère
au
voilà on a on est en train alors je
pense qu'on va pouvoir aller beaucoup
plus loin on va pas pouvoir aller
beaucoup plus loin parce qu'on a face à
nous je sais pas si on vous les voyez
habiba h voilà attention or on a face à
nous les manifestantes qui vous empêche
qui nous appellent d'avancé sur cette
place une file d'attenté où chacun
attend calmement son tour c'est inédit
dans un gta le jeu vidéo où il est de
bon ton d'enfreindre la loi ces
personnages attendent de se faire
vacciner contre locaux vides
le laboratoire pfizer installer un
centre de vaccination virtuelle dans la
version en ligne du jeu vidéo au brésil
l'objectif de cette opération marketing
et de promouvoir la vaccination auprès
des jeunes car une grosse ono a rejoint
vous avez bien car il avait le vide
tout ça tout petit plus la question
il ya un plexi
c'est pour ça qu'on a des meilleurs
chiffres dépassent
sur le
regard des raisons nous regarder le
nombril aussi tout le temps sur les
oiseaux s'il vous plaît vous parlez tous
les deux ensemble c'est insupportable
c'est comme karine le marchand c'est
magnifique mais qui ferme les yeux et
c'est juste du bruit
sachez qu'il ya deux mots qu'il faut
absolument éviter quand vous vous
disputez
non
samarie veille avant de me disputer hier
soir et puybasset les deux mots que
j'utilise tout le temps
toujours et jamais par exemple dit
oublie toujours tout fait jamais la
vaisselle veille parce qu'il faut les
éviter ce qui marque des exagérations
ils peuvent provoquer des nouvelles
disent mais complètement à nashville un
combattant de mma s'est disputé avec son
colocataire et lui a mordu les
testicules bilan trois points de suture
un litige qui se réglera devant les
tribunaux et la victime à une preuve de
poids je cite la preuve que j'utiliserai
au tribunal est littéralement un morceau
de peau qu'il est parti à m'arracher 6
cm ça casse pas une pâtée danger une
pâte et ruacana 1,3 paul allen ckoi
l'expression à camaret n'ont pas
toujours pas enfin ça casse pas des
briques 1 on parle d'une banderole c'est
pour ça que j'ai levé la tête une
banderole qui étaient là oh bien sûr ces
news fachos bon bout voilà enfin on a
droit on a droit à la totale sur cette
banderole c'est le maintien c'est l'île
des présentateurs télé du coup
je connaissais pas lille melon
mais ils
prévoient les grosses têtes
[Rires]
j'ai jamais vu autant d'insignifiance en
si peu de temps et et moi je regarde la
télé française